the state department came in and they
said that embassies around the world now
are not just going to fly the american
flag or the prisoner of war missing an
action flag
they also can and in some cases are
encouraged to fly
the rainbow flag the pride flag even at
the vatican seems a little disrespectful
to me
so i pointed out that the pride flag is
really not
no it's no longer just a representation
of sexual desire
that's what they want us to believe it
is but it's not it's a representation of
progressivism
it's a representation of american empire
because the american flag is a symbol of
the united states which is a real
country with real people with real
borders
but the rainbow flag is a universal
claim the rainbow flag
is just as true in tunisia as it is in
the united states right because it's
making claims about
human rights most broadly actually the
same is true of the black lives matter
flag
which is why the left favors those flags
because those are universal
imperialist flags rather than a specific
national flag because the left no longer
believes in nations
so the defense department came out and
said that they will not permit
their bases to fly the pride flag and
they were very cautious about this the
spokesman john kirby said
uh this is in no way reflects any lack
of respect or adver admiration rather
for the lgbtq plus community
this was really more about the potential
for other challenges that could arise
from that exception
and this is this is my point too this
actually isn't about
the sex stuff i i don't think that's
really what this is about at all i think
this is about
supplanting the american flag redefining
what flag symbolizes our country
for the left today the pride flag
symbolizes the country that they want
much more so
than the american flag does and it's a
it's about keeping the door closed to
what would happen if you put the pride
flag up then they're going to demand the
transgender flag then they're going to
demand the black lives matter flag and
they're going to demand
the antifa flag for goodness sakes
they're going to be flying the isis flag
by the time we're through
that is some good news that at least for
now the brass at the pentagon has put
the brakes on this sort of thing
but the elected officials not quite not
quite there
listen i'm just as shocked as you are
that we are still on youtube
but there's a fair chance you're not
getting notifications right now the way
to get notifications or to even have a
chance to get notifications
you ring that bell you like you
subscribe you will get the notifications
then by the way head on over to the
audio podcast apple podcast spotify
google play stitcher wherever you get
your podcasts
type in the michael knowles show
subscribe we'll see you there
[Music]
[Music]
you